all right the lion Kings officially like
a decade and a half old so I'm going to
talk about this movie with some spoilers
in it but if you haven't seen the Lion
King by now what The Lion King 3d
alright so I hadn't seen the Lion King
in a long time I just remember the Lion
King being like my favorite Disney
Animation and I sat down the theater and
the movie started and you see and hear
that intro that's all like I was like
awesome it takes you right back and the
intro is the best intro has like no
dialogue whatsoever it's just that
really classic Elton John song and
Rafiki is like inaugurating Simba or
whatever is holding him up like Michael
Jackson did with this kid over the
balcony so for me I was like alright I
haven't seen the Lion King since I was a
kid it's been years so I was really
interested I was like am I gonna like
the movie like I did before am I gonna
be like oh okay I liked it as a kid but
now it's just you know whatever that was
really surprised I really liked this
movie I was kind of giddy watching the
movie I haven't felt like that since I
was a kid probably watching the Lion
King for me the Lion King has everything
has a really cool father figure you know
it's Mufasa the voice of Darth Vader
James Earl Jones and that's an awesome
villain which happens to be Mufasa is
brother which happens to be Simba's
uncle has a relatable hero because no
matter who you are you've been in that
situation where you're like I got to
step up and do something I don't want to
do it though path of least resistance
that's more fun you know Hakuna Matata
and all that good stuff and who are we
kidding here ox at 90s hair middle part
perfectly and scar is like the baddest
of the bad he always has been he's
voiced by Jeremy Irons right there
you're like awesome as long as Jeremy
Irons isn't in Dungeons & Dragons he's
great but I mean he stages like the coup
of the century he prepares for the
murkiest scam he tries to kill Simba he
ends up killing Simba's father who is
his brother he takes over the pride
lands he just wrecks everything he's bad
and that Stampede seems like the coolest
thing ever
I remember the Stampede scene being the
coolest scene with the coolest music and
when I watched it today I was like wow
that's like the coolest scene with the
coolest music almost as cool as
because that is timeless right there
timeless intro and so when symbol runs
away he's just like you know what I'm
out I can't go back and just exile
myself he means Timon and Pumba I
remember Timon and Pumbaa being like all
right yeah they're kind of funny but you
know they're nothing special and I
watched it now I was like dude Timon is
the best I don't know why he just crack
me up like you know at the very very end
of the movie the last shot in the movie
when everyone's all standing up on Pride
Rock and I'll triumphant amongst I'll
doing this kind of thing you know I'm
like look at that guy taking credit
that's awesome good for you to moan and
it has the cat cheese music ever it has
like the coolest soundtrack because in a
Disney movie you're guaranteed certain
songs you have the intro song you have
the hero song you have the villain song
you have the friends song you have the
love song those are sure bets if they're
gonna be in a Disney movie in this one
they're all good when I was a kid I
liked The Lion King because I was like
oh I like Simba and the bad guy is
really bad and it's you know it's a
cartoon it has Lions and catchy music
and it's all good now I'm like oh I like
Simba and the bad guy is really bad and
it's you know it's a cartoon it has
Lions and catchy music and it's all good
and it's a good coming-of-age story
about stepping up and doing what's right
because you're obligated to do it you
know the little things in life and the
3d in this movies actually wasn't bad at
all it was actually pretty good so
apparently the only things that you can
convert into 3d after they've been 2d
and have them look good are animations
and CGI movies that's it I felt like a
kid again watching the Lion King but
appreciating the movie as an adult and
movies don't usually nail that so props
to the Lion King raise your kids on this
kind of stuff cuz there's a lot of
stupid stuff out there that will make
your kid dumb Lion King is not one of
them and you'll enjoy it too so that's
awesome raise your kids on stuff that
won't bore you good world so cool
characters good hero good story great
music and a great morality tale for
everyone to enjoy The Lion King is still
a classic the Lion King is awesome
tacular
people have asked me like Jeremy what
are your top ten favorite movies that's
really hard to do a top 10 list
Wow I would have to give a lot of
thought into that I don't know where the
Lion King would stand but I do know it
is somewhere in my top 10 favorite
movies of all time it always has been
and it always will be unless Hollywood
really steps it up now so your favorite
animated Disney movie what is it comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more